بغته ودون سابق انذار زلزلت الارض من
تحتهم ثوان قليله كانت كفيله بوقوع
الكارثه لم يتسنى فيها لبعضهم حتى النهوض
من سريره او احتضان ابنائه جميع انظمه
الانظار المبكر فشلت في تقديم اي اشاره
مسبقه لكن هناك من عرف بالكارثه قبل
وقوعها وتاكد بانها قادمه اللامحاله انها
الحيوانات
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
[موسيقى]
سلوكيات غريبه يلاحظها البشر على
الحيوانات منذ الاف السنين تنذر بوجود خطب
ما في كوكبنا وغالبا ما تكون كارثه طبيعيه
لا سيما الزلازل والبراكين وبشكل المفاجئ
تضطرب الحيوانات على اختلاف انواعها بشكل
مريب وتركض او تطير او تفر بلا وجهه
ايثانا بوقوع الكارثه
الى اليوم لم يتمكن العلماء من كشف سر
استشعار الحيوانات المبكر للزلازل الذي
يسبقها احيانا بساعات لكن هناك بعض
الفرضيات التي تفسر تلك الظاهره
ربما يتسبب ضغط الصخور قبل الزلازل في
تايين الهواء بشكل تستشعره جلود الحيوانات
وفراؤها وربما تشم الحيوانات رائحه
الغازات المنبعثه الضغط بلوره الكوارتز
قبل وقوع الزلازل وهناك تفسير بانها
تستشعر نوعا من الموجات يسمى
لا يشعر بها البشر عندما تم اكتشاف
الزلازل وضعنا اجهزه الكترونيه على ابقار
وكلاب واغنام في مكان قريب من الزلزال
ووجدنا هذه الحيوانات فائقه النشاط بشكل
غير عادي بعد ان كانت تتحرك باستمرار
لاكثر من 45 دقيقه لدينا مؤشر جيد على ان
الحيوانات تشعر حقا بمسببات الزلازل
استشعار الزلازل والبراكين ليس الامر
الوحيد الذي تتفوق فيه الحيوانات على
البشر فهناك مقدرات اخرى لبعض انواعها
يسعى العلماء اجاهدين لكشف اسرارها على
امل ان يساعد ذلك يوما ما في تطوير اجهزه
وادوات تساهم في حمايه الارواح
لاسيما من اخطار الكوارث
[موسيقى]